he's Christian McCaffrey the Panthers
running back taking eighth overall but I
guess technically you're still a student
as Stanford is that right Christian
oh yeah that's correct appreciate having
me on the show by the way thank you yeah
good to have you back but explain this
to me so you're not officially a
Carolina Panther you're still a student
at Stanford
well I've signed my contract and all
that but technically the rule is I can't
go inside the facility until Stanford's
graduation date which is somewhere June
and the team which is tough because I'm
not even enrolled right now obviously
and that's just the rule so I can't go
and we're on the quarter system so the
Stanford's graduation is pretty late so
it's tough so a lot of guys are
graduating this week and they can you
know go out but unfortunately I can have
you moved to North Carolina I have not
no yes I mean I can't I mean I don't
really I don't have a trainer anything
out there so I'm staying home right now
training and just skyping my coaches and
stuff which I'm allowed to do but I just
can't go inside facility all right you
did have the Panthers hat with you when
Trey Wingo on ESPN interviewed you and I
wanted to know if we opened up the
camera and had a wider shot how many
hats NFL hats did you have in the room
with you on draft night
all 32 yeah you just never know what's
going to happen so I don't where did you
think you were going like if you would
you know we know now you're happy where
you are but where did you think just
based on interviews or reaction you got
from a team you know I really had no
idea you know I'd heard some rumors just
going you know through the world but I
honestly had no idea it was one of those
things where you know I didn't want to
know I told my agent hey look you know I
know how the NFL is it to get him and I
don't you know I don't want to know so
until they get the call I'm just gonna
you know stay to what I'm doing and hope
for the best
why didn't you go to the draft I just
wanted to be in my hometown you know
where I grew up with my family and
home and I had some great family some
great friends there and I just you know
I wanted to be in Denver you know where
where it all happened you know what do
you remember about your dad's career
with the Broncos not a whole lot he was
uh you know in his career I was you know
pretty young so I didn't remember a
whole lot of far as the plane goes but I
remember you know how great the team was
to me and my brothers you know I'll
never forget when we were little we
would play Power Rangers you can't start
up in the las amazing you know stuff
like that all my life but I don't hold
out of the plane have you done YouTube
videos with your dad oh yeah no I've
seen Chris but yeah I just haven't seen
you know remember the live versions but
definitely I've seen the clips what did
the Carolina Panthers tell you and how
you're going to be used oh you know they
just think that'd be me now I'm running
back that's that's going to be my
position there but you know hopefully I
get the opportunity to split out a
little bit and just create mismatches
it's such a dynamic offense in such an
explosive offensive you know there's so
many great players to be used so for me
it's you know do whatever they tell me
to do you know whether it's from between
the tackles go outside and run some
routes or special teams so you know
right now just phoned in and I'm running
off and getting the plays down it
running back into you know see where
that takes me I compared the playbook
and with the Carolina Panthers to
Stanford oh it's actually it's very
similar thing that's one of the
advantages of going to Stanford is
playing and pro style often and so a lot
of the terminology and verbage is
different but the scheme is pretty
similar it's just a lot more you know
the NFL playbook is it has more plays
obviously than Bennett College playbook
so um you know it's tough in some sense
but it's very similar schematic and have
you talked to Cam Newton oh yeah I have
yeah as his birthday yesterday so your
birthday text but yeah he's a great
leader and I just can't wait to play
next to him you know what a player he is
too and I'm just I'm really excited for
what the office can do but I'm the
explaining are you going to be
every down back is that important to you
to be in every down back I know you want
to do whatever role they're asking you
to do but how important is it for you to
be that guy who gets 20 25 carries again
you know I love that I think you can I
think if you ask anything back in the
world if they want 20 25 carry they say
yes but you know I know that's not how
it goes I think that'd be a better
question for you know coaches with the
guys cuz I'm real right now I haven't
even stepped them Juliet I would love to
do that yes but right now I'm just
focused on doing my part you know
learning the play so I can get out there
and play fast you think you'll be hazed
when you get there the Panthers oh yeah
oh yeah yeah that's that's what comes
with being a rookie and you know we all
understand that but that's part of the
job everyone everyone has been there and
you know I'm I'm lucky I got I got some
great guys in the running back which no
guys like John Stewart and Fozzy
Whittaker just some of the older leaders
on that things it was you know been an
elite for a long time so you know I'm
just excited to learn from him through
uh do you want to go shopping with Cam
Newton you think he can help your
wardrobe.i I mean I think some people
say help some people say her out on a
you know I would not I would not deny
that because I need help the YouTube
video where you're working out now it
was that real speed or you know we tried
to imitate it and it felt like it might
have been what was it sped up a little
bit there Christian no it was not not at
all yeah if you listen to the music in
the background you can hear the lining
or playing in the background so it is
not sped up okay I appreciate that
that's a nice compliment yeah we did on
fashion but you got guys who are 40 or
50 years of age trying to emulate that
so my guys so it it wasn't a pretty
pretty sight is is four for eight really
indicative of your speed or could you
have done better
oh I definitely could have done better
you know I I wasn't very happy with my
forty time I've rinsed faster in the
past but you know I mean it is what it
is can't take it back but um you know I
I wish I ran faster
can you choose your number with the
Panthers I chose 20 peers between 22 and
a couple other numbers and I liked 22
the best and it was the first number I
ever wore little ball so it feels like
22 is fast or at least 22 better be fast
yeah I mean I hope I make it fast if
it's not but I like to think so I mean
there's been some great players that
wear it more number 22 so have you
graduated from Stanford or it's just
you're still a student so technically I
have not graduated yet okay all right
well enjoy your last couple of weeks
there is a student at Stanford and
congratulations good luck with the
Carolina Panthers
I appreciate that thanks a lot that's
Christian McCaffrey the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience